made by director max zela
from the hamburg media school in germany
the film raju tells a poignant story of
a german couple who traveled to india to
adopt a young orphan
all is well until suddenly the young boy
disappears without a trace all right
whoa thank you very much this is um
this is a great great honor and um
yeah there's my as my fellows already
said it was just incredible weekend
you know this is la so far away like so
far from germany so far from hamburg and
now i'm here now i'm here with my
colleagues
this is great and um i mean nine months
ago we were standing kolkata during the
monsoon uh it was thought it was very
humidity
we were standing there at night shooting
that film and tried everything to get
this film
done and nine months later i'm standing
on the stage of the academy this is just
wonderful thank you for that um i have
to say some thanks thanks to the film
school of hamburg media school who
really believed in that project who
believed in us um doing that film
and believed in us really that we got
this film done it was kind of a risk
actually shooting at kolkata i have to
um thank my both fellows
stefan gear please stand up the producer
of the film he's right there and sinhu
the dop the cinematographer
and
my wonderful girlfriend johanna pfaff
she also spin us with kolkata she
support us in everything
and um you have to
say great thanks to the great wonderful
actors uh watermelon
and they're like a-listed german actress
and they supported us they didn't get
any money and they came with us to
kolkata and uh i think they did a
wonderful performance also the little
indian boy chris gupta hello to calcutta
and um
i mean i just have to read it up if it
then so i didn't forget anything and i
mean i have to thank all the people in
kolkata actually because we had such a
great indian crew were like 50 people
from the indians and they all helped us
and they all believed in the project and
um
yeah and chatter zom
they helped us with the research on that
a serious topic and now the film is out
the topic is out how people talk about
it
and yes thanks a lot thanks to the
academy
thank you very much